that Germany so again with that
cd 5 I didn't even have today
we'll talk the devil
play so much now the three
yes seems to know their
way around so you can play
the whole thing is a bit uncomfortable too
black
so
falls here and then g4 g5 is just  such
an
automatic on roller
so I'm trying to see if I can get a game against this
yes what happens now if I jump
so that the seven games can he then
somehow already be there but
not like
I
jumped g4
yes yes well that's of course dangerous
everything ne
wii clear
maybe get a bit against the games
in the middle
you also have the idea maybe since there
are six of us here
between checkmate on a2
and i mean he ca
n't do anything directly now i think i'll
go five hangs  So first of all, or
if he takes it first, we have
seven here, we can then hang on
again,
and I have the field d 50 for the
jump  get
it so now you could of course be so
stupid six games
and somehow curb that of
course maybe the
possibility of sacrificing the dirt somewhere a bishop h6
and so on
anyway I probably
still have to do it
examines
yes but what if I have a
tower for example
does it make me runner f8 son
then yes eva is hanging
and i still have this between
ideas with the ie6 and so a
moment i can play straight away since i have six it
is also good because a
second apartment threatens four
yes
that is the question here  can you can
here you can even sacrifice here maybe
or just back
but then he can take here
springer
d3m springer 4
okay that doesn’t end well
oh i’ll try to recognize it as a sacrifice
is just how is at least interesting
probably it doesn’t work but
the  we will need a line
now i have two pawns
this funny one here the scattered one
but you can use it as a distraction  purposes can be
quite good of
course now so that the 54
so that the 52
so so that the 5a
would also like to sacrifice here
yes I had already mentioned that the
sacrifice is probably not possible
yes ok
here anyone
else gives nothing more
however there is not much threat of
that  victims quite dubious
so ok atoms 3.3
the distraction farmer
and then does makes
thomas doesn't work at all
what you can do again only differently here
but now
there can still be done exactly with it the
whole time didn't play seppel
mannomann say yes good about that  I was about
one character less and nothing on the
clock and of
course it was
played
stupidly well
I guess
well
not even a trick works here and
I have five seconds
yes okay that four weeks sacrifices were
obviously just total and correct